l'état sont parfois si haut qu'on se
croirait dans une guerre de tranchées
d'un côté l'administration plantes et
les déneigeurs de la mer et de l'autre
côté les montréal est pas certain d'être
les meilleurs dans la rue sans aucun
sens faudrait qu'ils se magne
dégueulasse la mairesse n'avait rien à
dire sur l'arrondissement où elle habite
mais moi ben heureusement entre quand
les trottoirs oui mais ce n'était
visiblement pas le même heureusement que
celui de daniel lopez qui nous a envoyé
cette photo ce matin même chose un peu
plus au nord de la ville une photo de
paul doyon dans ahuntsic
alors est ce qu'on est vraiment les
meilleurs ah ouais on vient de belgique
de vladivostok
on vient de beijing pour voir comment on
travaille ici je peux vous dire qu'après
avoir passé le style elle est passée
avec la fédération des déneigeurs russe
de russie je peux vous dire qu'ils
étaient extrêmement impressionné
quatre jours après la tempête 43 % des
russes ont déneigé on vise la moitié
demain mais on trouve encore des
trottoirs comme celui ci ou celui là qui
demande une performance d'équilibriste
où les pistes cyclables souvent déneiger
avant les trottoirs puis il ya toujours
ceux pour qui c'était mieux avant aucune
conscience environnementale on jetait
tout cela n'influe avant je t'ai la
neige laisse elle les cochonneries et
qui viennent avec
il ya donc ces trottoirs mal déneigées
par endroits mais aussi des
accumulations de neige à certaines
intersections qui peuvent atteindre plus
de deux mètres et qui gênent la
visibilité et auxquels vont s'ajouter
encore 10 cm je dis ici mathieu prost
radio canada montréal